mamma ho perso l'aereo ciao e benvenuto
in un nuovissimo video
in questo momento siamo a 998 mila
iscritti al canale ciò significa che
siamo quasi al milione se non l'avete
ancora fatto mi raccomando iscrivetevi
al mio canale e cliccate sulla
campanella vicino al tasse di iscrizione
attivando tutte le notifiche per
ricevere una notifica a tutte le volte
che pubblico un nuovo video
allora come sapete in questi giorni
storia ordinando sto mettendo a posto e
riordinando trovato questo reperto
storico è un quadernetto d'anelli a
righe per la precisione con una
copertina di dubbio gusto ma come dicono
gli antichi non giudichiamo il quaderno
dalla copertina
perché quello che conta è ciò che
troveremo al suo interno ma prima di
addentrarci all'interno di questo
quaderno vi devo raccontare da dove
tutto è partito come tanti ragazzi e
ragazze e anche io ho fatto delle
vacanze studio
questa è la storia della mia terza
vacanza studio
l'ultima aveva all'incirca 15 16 anni e
la meta era l'inghilterra questa vacanza
studio ahimé è stata tragica tragica
perché io volevo andare nel college
insieme agli altri studenti e invece mia
mamma ha voluto mandarmi famiglie
diciamo che di tutte famiglie a me è
capitata la regione era una coppia con
una figlia questa figlia
ogni sera si portava a casa uno diverso
mila euro cibo confezionato e in scatola
che in inghilterra è ma anche una cosa
normale problema era che da parma 3
volte io leggevo nella confezione che il
cibo era scaduto
l'ufac infine me inutile dirvi che
fingevo di sentirmi poco bene e poi
andavo al mcdonald's che è sempre una
garanzia quando sei all'estero
il punto era che una volta arrivati a
scuola prima di iniziare le lezioni
penso che si faccia sempre così fanno
una sorta di test per vedere qual è il
tuo livello di
se per poi insomma metterti nella classe
adatta al tuo livello di inglese
le opzioni sono due o nella mia scuola
erano molte prove a insegnare l'inglese
o di altri erano delle pippe perché sono
arrivata in una classe dove gli altri
studenti avevano all'incirca 40 anni non
mi dimenticherò mai
primo giorno direzione si fa un bel
cerchio per presentarsi nome cognome età
da dove vieni eccetera quando ho detto
che avevo 16 anni mi hanno guardato
tutti così che ci fai qui me lo chiedevo
anch'io però ovviamente non potevo
cambiare classe è un altro episodio
tragicomico riguarda la musica come
tutte le adolescenti mi rifugiavo nei
momenti di sconforto e la musica tiravo
fuori mio ipad o ipod
comunque l mp3 ovviamente prima di
partire allora vittorio ipod con tutte
le canzoni che mi piacevano di più in
quel periodo tutte le canzoni appunto mi
davano più conforto più sostegno alla
mia anima di adolescente ribelle accendo
il mio mp3
appena arrivata in aeroporto a londra mi
rendo conto che non c'era nessuna delle
canzoni che io avevo messo c'erano solo
tipo 45 canzoni dei negramaro e 45
canzone dei subsonica parte dal
presupposto che i subsonica
vi piacciono molto i negramaro in gruppo
che io adoro
però diciamo che eco in vacanza studio
da sola lontano da casa
preferivo qualcosa di un po più allegro
e quindi già lì il primo giorno avevo
capito che qualcosa qualcosa qualcosa
non quadra non si qualcosa non quadrava
un altro momento tragicomico è legato al
cibo perché appunto la famiglia che mi
ospitava mi dava da mangiare merda
quindi come ho detto prima
mangiavo spesso al mac un giorno ne ho
fatto una gita a londra perché appunto
stavo cina londra ma non è l'onda io
felicissima ovviamente non vedevo l'ora
e fare sciopero se l'avvocato niente
un soldo il mio momento tragicomico è
stato quando in lontananza ho visto
avete presente quel quei bar dove sai
che puoi trovare del cibo mangiabile
all'estero se non erro la catena pret a
manger ragazzi e sono entrata li ho
visto un panino pane e pomodoro e
formaggio
vi giuro ragazzi mi stavo per commuovere
la pelle d'oca ma riguarda ho mangiato
quel panino ragazzi come se fosse in
terre degli dei
diciamo quindi che non è stata la
vacanza studio dei sogni per per vari
motivi sicuramente ho imparato ho
perfezionato l'inglese ma bando alle
ciance il protagonista di questo video è
lui in questo quaderno ho iniziato a
scrivere una storia
quand'è che ho iniziato a scrivere
questa storia terminate queste due
settimane un vedevo l'ora ovviamente di
tornare a casa
secondo voi cosa può succedere ho perso
l'aereo
cioè vi rendete conto e io lo so che
adesso voi volete che vi racconti perché
ipercoop come è successo il tutto ma la
risposta nessuno qui perché io ho
iniziato a scrivere questa storia per
raccontare che stimo gnare ai posteri e
in questa esperienza traumatica del
perdere l'aereo di rimanere da sola a 16
anni uno degli aeroporti più grandi per
molto
partiamo subito ore 16 56 data 2 luglio
londra aeroporto di heatrow gente che
viene e che va gente in movimento gente
che aspetta partenze virgola sala
d'attesa una vetrata separa gli sguardi
persi dei passeggeri che attendono il
loro volo dal blu del cielo insolito per
londra ma in fondo gradito la gente che
aspetta è strana ma come si comporta
durante l'attesa si potrebbe coprire il
carattere gli abiti la vita stessa
anche un po filosofo c'è chi dorme c'è
chi si perde nel silenzio più profondo
c'è chi chiacchiera e prima o poi si
fermerà almeno si spera era anche
abbastanza comica c'è chi mangia
prendesse e c'è chi senza rendersene
conto fa tutto ciò e in più scrive ero
io
tra la relativa quiete di questa sala
d'attesa una ragazza siede su una sedia
una delle tante che ci sono qua dentro
ma lei al contrario degli altri sta
sfruttando questo momento d'attesa per
sfogarsi diciamo che questa ragazza è
complicata buffa e ha tanto forse troppo
da dire profilo psicologico dettagliato
è concentrata sul suo quadernetto e
scrive veloce perché questa volta le
sembra proprio di aver trovato la giusta
ispirazione quella che cercava da tempo
quella che le avrebbe dato la spinta per
raccontare tutto ciò che c'è nella sua
una felpa dai colori vivaci con strani
disegni della il suo senza artisti un
gis forse troppo o forse un po troppo
largo in vita che mostra un pizzico di
pancia capelli riccioli come il suo
carattere
no riccioli ribelli come suo carattere
raccolti in una coda disordinata proprio
come lei al suo fianco infatti c'è un
carrello vuoto che aspetta di essere
caricato uno zaino a terra strapieno un
paio di scarpe da ginnastica in
coordinato con la maglietta che mostra
la sua attenzione e il suo interesse
composto una sedia dove disordinatamente
ha posato il portapenne il portafoglio
beh all'aeroporto cosa è una tovaglia
sede è una grande idea
gli occhiali una canotta ma sabotatori
ci hai una cintura quella che dovrebbe
indossare ma per comodità si sarà tolta
durante l'attesa il quadro della
situazione è abbastanza chiaro adesso
procediamo con il raccolto
ore 18 e 05 eccomi qua stravaccata su
una sdraio
no no calma non sono ancora in spiaggia
già mi trova l'aeroporto di londra
aspetto il mio volo anzi in verità è che
il mio vero vero polo aspetto quell
altro volo sì sì posso capire che ci sia
un po di confusione in quello che ho
detto ma
la realtà è ora vi spiegherò meglio in
modo tale da potervi dimostrare che
anche se non sembra sto posto di mente
tra parentesi almeno credo sbadiglio
inizierò a innestarsi i primi segni di
stanchezza e la giornata più stremati
senza il mio e della mia vita
proprio così questa giornata non ha più
fine sono esausta non so neanche dove
trovo la forza di script ma voglio
andare avanti e rendervi partecipi ma
con chi stadio con chi stavo parlando io
parlavo già ai futuri marin che
diciamoci la verità queste due settimane
sono giunti al termine e stamane alle 8
e 30 sono partita per raggiungere
l'aeroporto di londra
verso le 10 30 11 sono arrivata il mio
accompagnatore se ne è andato ed è
iniziata la mia piccola avventura ho
fatto un primo giro ho mangiato qualcosa
e mi sono avviata fare il check in dopo
un po di coda mi dicono che presse
allora imbarco il bagaglio è più leggera
di prima vado verso i controlli passata
la dogana gli occhi non capiscono più
nulla
alla vista dei puntini negò compro
regalia mamma io che mia sorella anche
qualcuno per me giustamente soddisfatta
mi avvio e mi dicono di ripassare più
tardi ai controlli
un altro giro riprovo è ancora troppo
presto cioè io non vedevo l'ora di
tornare a casa e quando aveva già a
partire mi dicono di aspettare che
compaia sullo schermo il volo diretto
milano linate finalmente a fare il mio
volo
15 05 milano linate gate 18 vado c'è
altra gente che aspetta ci si imbarca ma
quando tocca a me per hugo dei tamburi
la signorina mi fa questa e linate
tu sei a malpensa
cosa cado dalle nuvole continuo a
insistere ripeto che io devo andare a
linate ma alla fine aveva ragione lei mi
affretto verso il gate per milano
malpensa e di nuovo altri controlli
inizia a salirmi una strana angoscia
forse perché mi sembra di ricordare che
il volo per malpensa era prima di quello
di linate prime domande non trovano una
risposta ma quando quella testa di
cavolo di tipo mi ha chiuso la porta in
faccia mi ha detto qualcosa che suonava
del tipo l'aereo partito prenotati per
quello dopo
non ci potevo credere assolutamente
senza parole chiamo mamma glielo dico
incazzata singhiozzando vicino a me una
voce di una ragazza mi ha sussurrato 6
tranquilla sono nella stessa situazione
francesca 24 anni aveva la coincidenza
da vancouver
anche lei aveva perso l'aereo un po mi
riprendo sempre scossa la seguo
chiediamo lo sportello della british
airwais il prossimo volo disponibile per
milano malpensa e alle 19 e 20 cielo
cambiano senza problemi e sono le 15 e
30 anto tempo dovrà aspettare cosa mi
inventerò per passarlo mi prendo un
cappuccino una brioche e l'east end su
questo sdraio dopo un po inizia a
chiamarmi tutta la famiglia tutti
preoccupati per me mi mancano voglio
arrivare a casa con 7 punti e scavati
sono le 19 05 e non è finita qui
e no perché da 15 minuti non sarò sulla
ero come previsto come questa ma
rivolgono anch'io da qualche minuto sono
voi da sapere che il volo dapprima
rimandato alle 20 è previsto per le 21
nov i ci voleva questa non è la
ricordavo allora qui ragazzi dovete
seguirmi perché è un passaggio
fondamentale matita ho scritto a matita
fino ad ora continua la storia ma con
una penna verde
vi chiederete perché perché non sono più
io a raccontare la storia ma è un'altra
persona eccola si alza la seguo si
stiracchia è distrutta povera piccola
mari sono già più di 10 ore che è
rinchiusa qua dentro in fondo sono cose
che succedono non la perdo d'occhio come
potrei lasciarla sola proprio adesso in
questa situazione in cui stare qualche
enorme matita quindi ritorna a
scrivere ma in a francesca che l'altra
ragazza che ha perso il volo e nella
sdraio vicino a me anche lei scrive ma
da cui non riesco a leggere e chissà
magari vicino a me ho un piccolo
leopardi o un mogol alle prime armi
non so dove riesco a trovare questa
leggera ironia ma alla fine il mio
intento è sempre stato quello di
prendere la vita con un sorriso almeno
di provarci voi una delle mie principali
caratteristiche e la solarità l'allegria
il più delle volte anche nei momenti
meno adatti ebbene tirarla fuori
o no ora dove giro sera guardo il
monitor
se tutto va bene tra un'ora solo in
aeroporto sono in aereo odio gli
aeroporti gli aerei e la british airwais
top ds come mai non hanno ancora detto
la porta d'imbarco
tra parentesi 20 e 15 21 e 30 non ci
posso ancora credere sono seduta in
aereo
anche se non è ancora partito ma
comunque mi sono seduta ed è già
qualcosa oddio ci stiamo muovendo
sorseggia un tè ci voleva qualcosa di
caldo tra mezz'ora
dovrei atterrare e qui per il gran
finale torna la penna verde e quindi
torna il narratore esterno dai mari
siamo quasi arrivati manca poco
ora starai pensando tutta questa fatica
per ritornare a casa
sì lo so non è stato facile ma tu forse
non lo sai o meglio lo sai ma non è
ancora pensato e programmato bene che
questo tuo apparente il ritorno in
realtà è la tua partenza la tua grande
partenza come per dove si forse ragione
non mi sono spiegato bene quindi è un
maschio normalmente quando qualcuno
parte sa dove arriverà che il luogo
raggiungerà ma io non sto parlando di
una partenza reale ma di qualcosa di più
questa è una partenza astratta
metaforica lo so purtroppo non è facile
da capire ma vedrai che in poco tempo te
ne renderai polpe solo in quel momento
potrai confermare di essere arrivata di
non avere più bisogno di me è solo
questione di tempo e pazienza stai
crescendo è più che mai hai bisogno di
una guida ed è per questo
io sono qui alla tipologia questo per
accompagnarti durante tutto il viaggio e
farti arrivare a destinazione nel modo
più semplice e veloce che ci sia
perciò se qui ogni mio consiglio ma
soprattutto ascolta il tuo cuore
dai su stiamo atterrando sei contenta
allacciate le cinture
stiamo arrivando anzi no scusa stiamo
partendo
[Musica]
cioè il narratore quindi era tipo una
mia guida mio angelo custode
allora sono curioso di sapere cosa ne
pensate
e se magari anche 463 cento se vi
ritrovate in questo racconto se voi
avete un diario se avete anche voi
scritto una storia del genere se avete
vissuto un'esperienza del genere io vi
giuro che l'altro giorno ho ritrovato
questo quaderno però non avevo letto che
ha detto lo leggo insieme a voi e come
avete notato cioè associati dei punti
che di giorno venuta la pelle d'oca
perché ho proprio rivissuto quel momento
soprattutto era un momento appunto di
transizione cioè da adolescente a bonn e
quindi questo finale con con la
guidatrice 6 tranquilla se cioè e la tua
partenza secondo me era intendeva quell
intendevo quello cioè mi dicevo da sola
stai tranquilla che questa esperienza
magari negativo la vacanza studio è solo
un
uno tipo dei tanti momenti difficoltà
che incontrerà in a tua strada
ma sarà così sempre deve essere forte
superare le cose no non la pensate anche
voi una sensazione strana c'è il bello
ma è triste lo stesso tempo sono
convinta che sarà un video lunghissimo
perché tra il racconto che vi ho dovuto
fare per forza per farvi capire di cosa
sta parlando e appunto la lettura del
libro sarà lungo ma spero i sabati di
piazza io vi mando un bacione enorme e
ci vediamo al prossimo bibbia